alors voici oui des caisses de félix la
directrice générale de l'adisq solange
drouin nous montre fièrement ses
statuettes de bronze et nous allons
distribuer combien cette année 50 53
karat un premier galop mais ça a changé
en quarante ans oui
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames mesdemoiselles bonsoir
messieurs ça remonte à loin
le premier gala a été présenté au bourg
dimanche
mais tout d'abord nous nous rendons à la
place des arts pour le grand festival du
10 à l'animation dodo et denise ce soir
c'est à votre tour de vous laisser
parler d'amour originale
[Musique]
y a pas un seul à faire une chanson
venus il ya 40 ans on remettait un félix
au micro sillon disco de l'année
remportée par toulouse
c'est là
où
c'est lui qui la traverse qui a eu
l'idée de créer l'adisq et son gala
notre industrie une autre association du
disque du spectacle québécois dit ce
soir un grand événement un grand
événement parce qu'avant 79
[Musique]
il y avait que de rares artistes du
québec qui était honorée à toronto aux
prix juno tanné de voir andré gagnon
ginette reno sandales et à toronto
chercher leur trophée
alors que on en fait réussi
on est aussi talentueux tenez que les
canadiens enlevés et c'est comme ça qu
andré gagnon a plu aussi être nommé chez
lui je suis très content d'avoir chez
moi au québec en anac
jérémy déjà quelques à 3 al hayya
solange drouin est à l'adisq depuis 26
ans
son plus beau moment au gala ça devrait
être un classique là avec céline dion au
centre bell au 20e anniversaire
g
céline dion descend du ciel à
l'intérieur de la planète terre elle est
l'animatrice du gala
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
b et jouer aussi la voici transformer à
un moment de la petite vie pour pas lui
annonce qu'il va devenir son gérant
pascal aussi bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
céline dion c'est la reine de l'adisq en
nomination 90 fois elle remporte 46
félix ou plutôt 45
parce qu'alain qu'elle a refusé je peux
pas accepter ce trophée là celui
d'artistes anglophones de l'année avec
son album en anglais et chez remercier
publie aussi parce que je pense que
d'autres ont compris que j'étais pas une
artiste anglophone
les tacles de l'année auteur compositeur
interprète autres scènes mémorables mais
richard je vais prendre soin de ce
trophée de la même façon que tu en
prends resteront quand l'animateur guy a
lepage a lancé à un technicien dans les
coulisses le félix de richard desjardins
le chanteur était en gaspésie guy a
lepage a depuis reconnu qu'il avait fait
une erreur de jugement
j'aurais dû trouver une façon de me
[ __ ] de sa gueule autrement à piffard
étonnement et on ne peut pas oublier la
sortie de luc plamondon
quand le président de l'adq est assis à
côté de minutes d'affaires culturelles
au d'écrire une lettre entre et
créateurs disant qu'on va acheter
l'industrie du spectacle par terre comme
un véritable temps sauf quand dans le
camp l'alleud
ça annonce des batailles au fil des ans
l'adisq cesse d'être un simple
organisateurs de gala et se transforme
en groupes de pression si vous aviez à
dire l'industrie musicale au québec il y
à 40 ans par rapport au jour d'hui est
ce qu'elle se porte mieux aujourd'hui
qu'il ya 40 ans oui on a une industrie
de plusieurs entreprises
bon elle a dit ce qu'on à 250 mans mais
les artistes de la production de deux
disques d'à peu près une centaine puis
on a une vingtaine d'entreprises solides
très très solide
[Musique]
solide mais fragiles financièrement
surtout avec l'arrivée décès de
diffusion de musique en continu
moi je suis chargé d'une telle chose de
l'argent parce que là on n'en peut plus
on est en train de mourir si on nous
aide pas
[Musique]
et d'argent ils pourront parler dimanche
au 40e gala de l'adisq avec leurs
invités de marques de premier ministre
du canada justin trudeau
[Musique]